para fines de simplicidad supongamos que
la tasa de conversión de divisas es de 6
jones chinos por cada dólar americano ok
y que a esa tasa china está exportando
50 millones de dólares en bienes a los
eeuu ahora eeuu está exportando 20
millones de dólares en bienes a china y
claramente hay un desequilibrio
comercial los eeuu están importando 50
millones de dólares en bienes y exporta
20 millones de dólares también en bienes
así que tiene un déficit comercial de 30
millones de dólares ahora en esta
situación el fabricante chino tendrá 50
millones de dólares que va a querer
convertir de sus ingresos en américa y
convertirlos en divisa china el
fabricante americano va a querer
convertir sus jones en 20 millones de
dólares verdad entonces aquí
así que la reserva de dólares que es de
50 millones justo aquí va a ser mucho
mayor mucho mayor que la demanda que es
de 20 millones de dólares así que si a
las divisas se les permite flotar el
dólar se debilitaría el costo del dólar
caería su reserva es mucho más grande
pero digamos que el banco central chino
no quiere que eso pase ok no quiere que
pase así que este es este es el banco
popular de china digamos
el banco popular de china y ellos no
quieren que la divisa china se
fortalezca porque si eso pasara entonces
los bienes chinos los bienes chinos
serían más caros en eeuu y sería más
difícil de mantener este desequilibrio
así que lo que esencialmente hacen es
reponer en la diferencia en la demanda
por él por el dólar
ok justo aquí sólo hay demanda para 20
millones de dólares acá hay una reserva
de 50 millones así que lo que hacen es
crear una demanda demanda por 30
millones y la forma en que hacen esta
demanda de 30 millones a esa tasa de
cambio pueden literalmente imprimir 180
millones de yuans ok 180 millones de
johann si a esa tasa de 6 a 1 pueden
salir al mercado salen salen al mercado
abierto y tratan de convertir esto en
dólares así que esto crearía una demanda
para un incremento de 30 millones de
dólares así que cuando ellos hacen esto
la demanda total de dólares es 30
millones más los 20 millones que ya
tenía
del fabricante americano completaría
exactamente la reserva de dólares a esa
tasa de cambio y así no causaría que la
tasa de cambio fluctuará o el balance
del comercio ok esto es muy claro en un
ejemplo muy simplificado mucho muy
simplificado los números actuales son
mucho más grandes que los millones son
del orden de billones de dólares ok pero
este nos da al menos en la mente una
buena idea de cómo el banco central
chino está actualmente manteniendo su
divisa anclada al dólar y cómo está
ayudando a mantener un desbalance
comercial reportando desde la canaca de
mí para la cnc